the girag an experienced Joe Frazier was
a motherfucker sad wasn't we used to go
to Philly we used to drive past his gym
on the way in from the airport they but
he lived at his gym before he died yeah
he went broke in the end look the amount
of money that these guys make for the
time look they're talking about five
million dollar purses for ollie
informant for the time you have five
million dollars back then that is a lot
of goddamn money but guess what you live
like you got five million dollars so
you're buying fucking Cadillacs and
paying for this and paying for that
meals here and jets there next thing you
know five million dollars and you make
it to the 80s and you know the brothers
are showing up at the door my long-lost
mo fucking closet yeah listen man we got
a venture and this motherfucker can't go
wrong barbershops on white neighborhood
first year gonna make 30 percent of your
investments second years 60 percent on
your vests man and they just hit you
with some crazy speech how many of those
you ever had to deal with three oh you
get them all the time I had to deal with
one recently movies TV shows you get
them consoles your beatings oh yeah do
it what I even come listen man I'm not a
movie producer all you have to do is
give us a check and we'll do the rest
oh you don't have to do anything you'd
have to worry about yes I do I have to
worry about it
no no you don't have to worry about it
no no I do have to worry about if I give
you money I'm gonna worry about it get
out of here you crazy idea there's a
reason why they have banks okay go to
the bank if you have a really good idea
and you have credit go to the fucking
bank if you don't have credit I gotta
assume somewhere along the line you've
already made some poor fucking choices I
don't want to be involved in that people
have this everybody has this idea that
they they're gonna figure out how to
circumvent this time-honored system of
Hollywood and we're gonna get to Joe
Diaz if I can get to chori as I know
Jody has been killing it on the road if
he can give me just $2,000 and I could
start this film you know Quentin
Tarantino this is my my my my my my
Kevin Smith made clerks and ran yeah and
they just think that all they need is
couple grand from Joey Diaz
Joey Joey Joey Joey you can't go wrong
okay nobody makes movies like me okay
Joey they just don't want me in they
don't want me and Joey take don't want
me and Joey Diaz they want to keep me on
the outside no you get him for your time
it's not even that you get him for money
you get them for your time yeah look at
you with your living through you you're
busy yeah you swamp there's no more no
someone I keep telling people that to
get mad at me no yeah they don't
understand what you have children
there's no schedule I can't count on my
schedule bro a 10 20 she wouldn't get
off my fucking lap yeah watching one two
three videos on YouTube at 10:30 yeah
she went to pick her up like let's go it
what yeah
what were you fucking talking about I'll
be back in a couple hours
don't you fucking talk you don't have no
fucking idea what it is to and I went to
get to go into the room at 9:30 to get
out of it I was gonna get out of the
early that a little bitch open the gate
up I heard those stomping and like that
there's no argument she just put Sansa
alright pick her up gonna put youtube on
I gotta sit there with a one two three
four or five you know and then she again
daddy okay well the problem people
asking to do things too is that you kind
of do this shit for yourself okay the
way to do it is not to go through other
people and ask people to pick you up and
help you that's not how it works doesn't
work that way everybody thinks are going
to figure out some fucking joke shortcut
because they know you or they know this
guy or that guy this there's no
shortcuts in creating something just
figure it out bitch I love stand up
because there's one part of me it
doesn't need anybody I'll even open who
right here this is my tools for stand-up
at a person we're gonna go to Bob's
fucking coffee house on North Hollywood
and do three minutes you know me I don't
never fuck yeah when we talked about
having a band that somebody came on here
and said that it was the toughest thing
in the world for a band to stay together
you got four people personalities you
know you get these people that come to
you now and I was breaking it down for
you on the plane they don't say hey Joe
are you doing my name is read my script
do you like it here we're gonna get
eight million dollars and then you go
okay when you get it call me I really
like the script something you're
interested in whatever three days other
thing you do get a call in a year later
they say hey we're making a movie but
guess what we didn't get two million
dollars we got two hundred thousand
dollars so instead of you getting ten
thousand a week and I get a hundred a
day
and it's gonna be a hit we're gonna make
it happen nine other ten they run out of
money for marketing and editing and the
whole fucking things to your movie ends
up in YouTube
they don't have a legit schedule so you
have to work Saturdays and fucking
Sundays you know those people that are
involved in those low rent movies
they're a fucking nightmare and it's
their dream and I get it's your dream
but don't include me in this fucking
thing because you want me to do
everything cheap on my end all the hours
and it's your fucking dream if it's that
much you're dreaming do me a favor
forget the 200 G's we'll get another 300
G's and make this fucking work but not
only that you can find other actors out
there that will do it for cheap there's
people out there that just want to act
sort of a comic will go to an open mic
night there's certain actors that just
want to do something to put it on a real
go find them there's a lot of talented
people out there that are not working as
far as like acting goes there's a lot of
fucking people that can do it there's a
lot of lovely people it's just the I
just have a problem people like asking
you to help them do it like I get it
from comics all the time to just looking
for a break what are you talking about
just you're not you're not gonna get a
break from another comic the way you get
breaks is by going on stage and being
funny like go to an open mic night be
funny the club will say hey Joey Diaz
you're fucking funny we would like you
to come here more often the audience
really enjoyed you next thing you know
some manager says you know what Joey
Diaz you're really funny we would like
to think about taking you on as a client
and that's how it works like a comic
coming along is not gonna make you
funnier and then the people that do that
they always have a distorted perception
of how good they are already you know
those those kids that are asking for a
break the kids that want you to help him
hey manage need a break if I could do
guess that for you really help me like
that's not you don't you don't go to the
Doug Stanhope show and ask for a fucking
guest all our Doug probably put you up
dr. Berger alright 2:15 starting to go
up front
Doug will push a parking open micro and
its first time on stage he'll do that in
front of like a crowd in Norway or
something but that stand-up you know uh
it's not normal yeah you have to do you
it's amazing what people you know we
weren't like that thank God we knew that
this took work and hard we knew that
this wasn't going to happen in one night
I was old enough already when I started
I was longer the truth already
that I knew this was just not gonna you
know you just didn't walk on stage and
things happen and people come here and
they call Desperados where they just do
don't
up to you for a guest saying you're
gonna ask him what is this gonna do for
you right how's this gonna fuckin change
your life it's like I've never been too
much of a hanger out I don't believe in
that I never believe in that shit you
know I believe in doing this spot if I
go to the Connie circle I'm doing the
fucking spot if I don't go I don't go to
the improv my name isn't on that list
the Hangout there's no for me there's no
no no no because if you come up to Joe
Rogan red band or Jamie and go hi Jamie
my name is Joey Diaz I'm a fucking
account I'm a funny comic Jamie's gonna
say are you going up tonight cuz we all
want to watch you I love to laugh but
you're funny let's go no I'm just here
hanging out you hate that fucking funny
if you're not on the list you ain't that
fucking funny or they don't know about
you yet there's a possibility though no
no no we're certain people that go to
the improv that's it and I'll tell you
dog you've got a network what network
your network onstage i network onstage
yeah when they laugh and I walk off
that's networking well not only that
when you're a comic you're sort of like
a fruit or a vegetable in that you're
you're growing and then you get one day
you can be ripe and when you're gonna be
ripe everyone's going to know about it
people find out about you people people
found out about everybody they found out
about you they found out about
Hinchcliffe they find about everybody
here about Duncan you know what happened
what's happening in China right now
what's happening in child always packing
them in oh yeah every night he goes I
can't believe there's white people and
UFC fans in China you're coming from
money out yeah okay they're not big
rooms they're 120 seed onion Z this is
like coffee shops right but we're on the
Internet
this shit isn't worldwide this is
worldwide yeah this is you can't believe
it that there's fucking people walking
around here going we came to see you
from Macau I can't believe it took
people for so long to figure it out
Ari's a fucking genius he's a great
comic it's uh it's just amazing that
people have misled they think they
shortcut we got here what was the
shortcut if you get out of the Tonight
Show right that's it how many people
have gone on The Tonight Show not great
success
no one cares a lot of people now it
doesn't know but back in the day it
meant something big you know Steven
Wright days well I could finally do a
technical get up a Turkish get up no I
technical get up in jujitsu I could
finally do it after a year practicing in
hotel rooms five a day I would do on my
right side
for everything I'm a nut dog right you
do know I'm retarded half what people
know that I'm a little stupid
I'm geeky you're not I don't like I
don't like being bad at something and
since we got the comedy work that ethic
I know that you could turn anything in
life into something if you just keep
showing up yeah if you just you know
like for me to Jitsu has been I suck Joe
but I can finally do the whole Jim hip
escape that fucking I'm a black belt in
HIPAA escapes to me today that's what I
do I'm a hip escape expert that's what I
work on you know uh this game's a huge
bro fuck and when you learn how to doing
for you six months I know what I was
doing and then salami taught me
sometimes all just taught me a different
I put it all together on my shoulder and
now at least I could pick up my ass and
push it all the way back for me those
are little things you know I wish I was
better but I know if I keep going to
jujitsu twice a week which is what my
body can handle eventually I'll get
something on bar eventually cuz I got
funny with comedy I was no fucking to
slip Magoo in the beginning I just let
my girl whatever girl I just kept
showing up though you just got to keep
showing the fuck up that's half a life
that's half a life and who gives a fuck
our I'm not looking for a black belt I'm
not even looking to go to beat nobody up
I'm just looking to go to learn Turkish
get up I could do with ten pounds a
Turkish getup I'm up to this point where
I put my arm down I put my knee up and I
just go up to my elbow and I go down I
do ten of those bro bop bop bop I don't
even go over I've been doing it fate
months kettlebells 10 pounds Turkish get
a bitch but I'm still doing it right
what would happen if I would it took 35
pounds
you know me dawg I get that I wouldn't
be here right now my shoulders being my
fucking halo so but at least I know this
going in be crying loudly because of the
lesson I got from comedy that it don't
matter though just keeps you know yeah
yeah but nobody lasts dog keep showing
some people you chumps stay home some
people just don't want man
for some people it's like me that every
when we did comedy
there was eight people who had a chance
there was another six who were funny but
they had day jobs because they were
married I had children then you had two
people who do it as a hobby that
be once in a great while they drove to a
gig and then you got three people that
just had mental health issues yeah okay
he's always showed up every week and
they were nice enough but you knew there
was something wrong there and for them
it was the way this is for me with
jiu-jitsu
I'm not looked for that me they're not
looking to be on MBC all they want to do
is one time in their life make somebody
laugh how special is that it's huge and
they go down it and you miss those guys
I miss those guys from my scenes and see
how even here and then lay there's
people that you see them and they're a
pleasure to talk to because they don't
want an agent they don't want to be on
movies they're just having fun they work
at Universal City in the daytime as the
hope you know it's very few of those who
appreciate that I respect that man but
there aren't they're very there's very
few of those most of those guys have
dreams that just never manifested
themselves but a lot of them never
material I met a lot of guys that bro
they were proud of their job they just
got somewhere in their life I take it be
a stand-up and they just didn't want to
die without trying it right and then
they did it they become addicted how
many people go to jiu-jitsu it becomes
addicting yeah Stan definitely becomes
addicted and it becomes updates that it
becomes addicting and it's like addicts
where you see those guys are scrambling
outside they can't wait to get on stage
and like even guys are bad they'll see a
guy who's up there killing like you be
up staring like man he's supposed to
only be doing 15 minutes motherfuckers
or 20 minutes like what do you care what
are you gonna do you're gonna go up
after Joey Diaz what are you gonna do
you're an open mic ER and you're upset
like they think somehow another thing
I'm on the non-paid regular list but
you're not getting up until 2:00 in the
morning you know how it works this is
what you do you're in a non-paid I was a
non-paid regular you get up after
everybody else that's what you do if
there's anybody fuckin craziest that
people should notice you wanna you were
on a TV show and you weren't on pay
regular which by law if you're on a TV
show you're allowed to go in there and
bump bitches mm-hmm even the Bell yeah
I'm saying well not only that I showed
up every night every night I was there
every night I have anything this lesson
I learned about this whole thing from
you it was news radio on Fridays you got
there 11:00 in the morning wardrobe
stupidity laughter food and then they
eight o'clock your shoot you'd be
strolling in there
11:30 bro I respect you for that to this
day that meant more to me and you didn't
need it it's $15 it's not like you had
19 kids you need the 15 fucking dollars
but I'll tell you the truth being passed
as a paid regular at the college tour
meant more to me yeah getting on a TV
show
me too when I was on a TV show when I
was on Newsradio one of the things I
love about you coming to visit me is
like finally there's another
motherfucker doesn't belong here
cuz I was I was always wandering around
like one day they're gonna tell me to
get the fuck off TV but until now
somehow or other I'm on TV so Joey would
show up I black come here man hey come
on let me show you what this is this is
where they keep the food please wander
around the set Joey would show up at the
set and Joey be sitting they had an
executive VIP suite and the VIP suite
they had shrimp cocktails and delicious
hors d'oeuvres and they had it catered a
dude who you know had like one of those
Mumford & Sons fucking facial hair
things with a beautiful tie a thin
skinny time he'd be like serving people
shit and it would be all these NBC
executives and Joey fucking Diaz with a
leather jacket would stroll in and feast
he'd be sitting there with a fucking
paper plate with like 15 shrimps on it
oh my God look is that your friend
you